au pin a vite c'est très urgent du
diamant qu'est-ce qui se passe
tu avoir un bébé un trip quotidien
avancée vient voir certains déchets que
dans ta face
salut tout le monde je sais ce que vous
vous dites tous vos yeux ne sont pas
habitués à autant de couleurs et de
gentillesse et bien des habits mais ça
c'est parce que vous avez vu trop de
films tristes mais plein d'antihéros
déprimé et il est temps de faire entrer
un peu de soleil dans vos vies
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce qui se passe je suis la
reine board des hard rock roll la reine
du rock
je vais détruire toutes les musiques
sauf le rac s'étaient tissés la mériter
ce qu' il existe d'autres sortes de
troll aussi vrai ces trois là ne sont
pas comme nous quoi nous serons tous
différemment les danses qui fait rage
ils sont différents à moins que tu ne
veux même pas imaginer
joyeux anniversaire
peu importe les différences nous devons
unir tous les trolls pour empêcher par
de découvrir la musique
je viens avec toi
ok ça lui
hu
à moins vous demanderai le même look et
ferait le même son époque l'harmonie
je vais unir les trolls autour d'une
seule musique
notre musique je me faisais frais de me
battre que quand j'aurai tout remis en
ordre musclée
comment on va s'en sortir et pour voir
ce cabinet je vous protégerait quoi
qu'il arrive c'est promis juré
tu ne peux pas revenir sur un premier
jury
j'y crois pas les jurés
[Musique]